scp-682 versus scp-101  could the hungry bag finally be the  anomaly that doesn't find the  hard-to-destroy reptile too tough to  swallow  scp-101 the hungry bag is a small  tooth-lined bag seemingly connected to a  limitless pocket dimension capable of  devouring almost anything dr lee roy  carlson suggested it might be perfect to  finish off 682 after it was reduced in  size by another anomaly so after scp-682  was shrunk down by a confrontation with  scp-165-1  its tiny body was thrown into the gaping  maw of scp-101  and swallowed up later however scp-101  began to gurgle for an extended period  after a prolonged period of discomfort  it belched up the tiny scp-682  which later returned to its normal size